[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد للتطبيع مع نظام الاسد
تفاصيله كثيره تتمسك بها جهات دوليه فعله
كالولايات المتحده التي ترفض اي تطبيع مع
دمشق بل وتدعو دول العالم الى عدم التطبيع
مع الاسد دعوه استمرار القطيعه تلك صدرات
ايضا مؤخرا في معرض تعليق واشنطن على
اللقاء الذي جمع بين او في موسكو وزيرى
الدفاع السوري والتركي المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه
وخلال لقاء بالصحفيين وصف بشار الاسد
بالديكتاتور الوحشي كما اكد رفض واشنطن
تعزيز الدول لعلاقاتها معه او تقديم الدعم
له مضيفا ان رئيس السوري واصل وفي الوقت
الراهن ارتكابه فضائح ضد الشعب السوري كما
يمنع وصول مساعدات انسانيه عاجله
لمحتاجيها في المناطق الخارجه عن سيطرتي
قواته الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا جدد موقفه
الرافض لاي تقارب مع نظام الاسد واكد ضرو
الضغط عليه للانخراط في عمليه سياسيه في
المقابل روسيا التي تعاني عزله شبه دوليه
تكثف اتصالاتها للحفاظ على قوه الدعم
والدفع في مسار التطبيع بين انقره ودمشق
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفي من موسكو
الدكتور رونالد بيجاموف المحلل السياسي
وربما يلتحق بنا بعد قليل ضيفنا الثاني من
باريس سابدا معك دكتور رولاند دكتور
رولاند في الواقع البعض يقول بان روسيا في
الوقت الحالي ليست في احسن ظروفها حرب
مفتوحه على مصراعيها امامها وهناك ضغوط
اقتصاديه
تتعبها يوما بعد يوم اكثر فهل موسكو
لازالت تدعم فكره الدفع بعوده النظام
السوري للحضن الدولي تعتقد
مساء الخير يا اعتقد انا كل هذه الامور في
الدرجه الاولى عوده سوريا الا الاسره
العربيه هي تخص العرب انفسهم في الدرجه
الاولى جامعه الدول العربيه روسيا فقط
تستطيع ان ترحبوا هذه العمليه ولكن يجب ان
نعترف بانه ما نشهد اليوم هو فقط المصائب
في استئناف
الاتصالات بين بعض الدول العربيه في
الدرجه الاولى مصر والاردن وربما المملكه
وعوده النظام السوري للحضن العربي هذا
ناقشناه في الجزء الاول نحن الان نتحدث عن
مدى امكانيه عوده العلاقات شبه عاديه او
تطبيع العلاقات مع نظام السوري دوليا
روسيا تطمح لذلك هل هي قادره عليه فعلا في
هذه المرحله
اولا هذا في الدرجه الاولى لا يتوقف على
الاراده الروسيه والمصلحه روسيا روسيا
شريك
لثلاث دول العلاقه الحاده
كضامن للامن في سوريا
وشاركت هناك في تخفيض
التساقط
ولديها هناك قائده عسكريه
وقيدتين الجويه
والبحريه ولكن في نفس الوقت امكانات سوريا
محدوده في الدرجه الاولى هذا يتوقف العديد
من العوامل على الاطراف الاقليميه الاطراف
الداخليه في سوريا نفسها وفي خارجها ولكن
هذا كل هذه الامور
ستطلب مزيدا من الوقت ولكن
قبل كل شيء هو بنسبه الى روسيا الموضوع هو
المصالحه الوطنيه
والاستقرار في هذه المنطقه هو في ذاته
هيصاعد سيصاعد
على تخفيض التوتر العالمي
في الشرق الاوسط وهذا الشيء يتطبق كليا
مبادئ
العقيده للوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه فيما
يتعلق هذه المنطقه
السياسي دكتور اهلا بك معنا ضيفي يتحدث عن
شروط يقول بان ان كنت سمعت لنا منذ قليل
يقول بان روسيا حتى وان تحدثت وصرحت بان
هناك دعم للنظام السوري ولكن هناك وضع
يحدده الداخل السوري يجب ان تكون هناك
مصالحه يجب ان يكون هناك استيعاب عربي
وفيما بعد يمكن ان تكون هناك دفعه دوليه
هل تعتقد بان المجتمع الدولي جاهز
لفتح الباب من جديد امام النظام السوري
مساء الخير اعتقد انه في الدرجه الاولى
السوريون المعارضون لنظام الرئيس السوري
الاسد مساكين انهم لاجئين في دول الاغتراب
انهم مظلومين وعددهم يتجاوز 12 مليون شخص
اي نصف الدوله طردهم النظام من اراضيهم من
بلادهم فلا يمكن الاعتماد عليهم
للاعتراف لاعاده سوريا الى المسرح الدولي
فيما العرب هناك يعني كل زملاء بشار الاسد
من القذافي الى بن علي الى
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح والى الرئيس
مبارك في مصر كلهم تركوا السلطه
بطريقه مغلوبين ومطرودين ولم يعودوا في في
في على قيد الحياه في حين ان الرئيس
السوري ما زال يمسك بزمام
وبدل ان يستجيب لاراده الشعب طرد الشعب من
الداخل السوري فاذا هناك عدد من الدول
العربيه
الى حد ما تقول انه هذا الرجل
ما زال صامدا
يعني
للواقعيه سيعترفون به وهناك مصالح هناك
مثلا دوله خليجيه تعتبر ان سوريا هي افضل
سفير تجاه ايران
لحتى يعني ايران ترفع يدها عن الصواريخ
التي ترسلها الى هذه ولكن لما نتحدث عن
صحيح ولكن لما نتحدث عن المجتمع الدولي
سيد
رولاند البعض يقول بان لا يمكن ان نتحدث
عن سوريا دون الاشاره الى كل الاطراف التي
فاعله في السابق ولا زالت تفعل على الارض
السوريه نتحدث عن روسيا نتحدث عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نتحدث عن ايران التي
يعني
اكدتم على حضورها وعلى
قوه تاثيرها على القرار السوري ونتحدث
كذلك عن تركيا اليوم واشنطن سيد رولاند
ترفض رفضا تاما ان يكون هناك اعتراف دولي
بنظام السوري هل تعتقد بان هذا الرفض
سينسحب على كل الاطراف الدوليه او ان هناك
شيء يحضر حتى بدون موافقته واشنطن
موقف الولايات المتحده معروف يعني
الولايات المتحده تاره
تدعم
السياسيين في بعض الدول الرؤساء يعني خدمت
لمصالح الولايات المتحده واذا لا تخدم
لمصرخ الولايات المتحده يتم
وصوة
وحول الناس بارضاء البشريه من
وغيرهم من النوت ولكن انا متاكد ان
الولايات المتحده مع قدراتها وامكاناتها
اذا كانت بالفعل مهتمه باسقاط الرئيس بشار
اسد لا اما لا كل شيء ما بوصلها بمخابراته
او باموالها
بثرواتها لاسقاط هذا النظام في مفهومهم هو
النظام ولكن يبدو ان هذا لا لماذا لماذا
يصب في مجرى السياسه الامريكيه ولكن ما هو
مجر ى السياسه الامريكيه لماذا ابقت عليه
وفي المقابل كانت سلطت عليه مثلا قانون
قيصر الذي تم تفعيل سنه 2020 والذي شددت
من خلاله هي العقوبات على النظام السوري
ليس الهدف الرئيسي للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وعلى فكره هم حتى اذا ارادوا ذلك لا
يمكنهم فعل ذلك لان من مصلحه الولايات
المتحده اداره الفوضى في سوريا وفي جميع
الدول العربيه وفي جميع دول المنطقه بما
في ذلك تركيا وايران وغيرها من الدول
الجامعه الدول في الشرق الاوسط في مفهوم
في نظريه
نيوكونس هي مستهدفه بما في ذلك حتى مصر
مثلا كانت مستختفه وغيرها من الدول
الامريكيه
معروفه وعلى قاده الدول الحدث التواخي
بالخجل الرئيسي على الارض السوريه طيله
سنوات مضت ليست من مصلحتها ان تنتهي هذه
الازمه
في الواقع الخطيئه الكبرى ارتكبها الرئيس
اوباما عندما حذر الاسد من استخدام
الكيماوي واذا فعل فسيرد اوباما الولايات
المتحده واذا به الاسد يجرب
اوباما واوباما يتراجع ومنذ ذلك الحين فهم
السوريون وفهم الروس وفهم الايرانيون انهم
يستطيعون
الاقدام على ما يخططون عليه ولذلك استوحش
الاسد اكثر فاكثر وتراجعت امريكا ولم يعد
عندها صفه الرضع في سوريا الى ان وصل
قانون قيصر والصور ال500 الف صوره للذين
عذبوا في اجهزه مخابرات السوريه
وعندها صدر هذا القانون وهو موجع لسوريا
في الواقع
تجربه الولايات المتحده في تغيير النظام
في العراق لم تكن مجديه فربما يكون تكون
اليوم ان يحاصر النظام ويترك حتى يسقط
ما حصل من زلزال في تركيا وسوريا انقذ الى
حد ما النظام واعاد اليه نظر العالم بشكل
مختلف
فالتوحش
السيطره على الساحه والزلزال
بدل ان يزيحه يعني
اود على كل سيبقى موضوعا المتابعه
على المشاركه من موسكو دكتور رولاند
السياسي ومن باريس الدكتور انطوان بسبوس
الكاتبه السياسي شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]